I've been talking since Donald Trump was inaugurated,
that, uh, as much as we have to cover the
scandal of the presidency and the embarrassment
of the presidency and the farcical nature
of the presidency, we also have to keep our
eye on the things that are done under the
cover of that scandal and embarrassment and
farce.
And we've talked about
the extremist reactionary judges that have
been installed likely to impact the judiciary
for a very long time after Donald Trump has
gone.
And I've talked to you about the ruined relationships
with so many countries around the world, which
will take a while to repair long after Donald
Trump has gone.
We've talked about the environmental deregulation
that's been done by Donald Trump and Republicans
allowing more pollution and more destruction
of the planet and dirtier water and more and
more lacks food safety standards.
And I have that type of news for you today,
which is that the United States conducted
a record setting number of bomb drops over
Afghanistan in 2019 what?
What?
How didn't we hear about this?
What happened?
How is this possible?
It is the air forces central command published
the numbers, 7,423 bombs, seven four two three
bombs were dropped on Afghanistan last year.
That's the highest number in more than a decade,
supposedly we weren't really in that war anymore.
Remember, you have to go back to 2011 for
a higher number of bombs dropped on Afghanistan.
And at that time we did think that we were
at least sort of at war there.
So on the one hand publicly, Donald Trump
has said he's open to reducing troops in Afghanistan,
ending Wars, all of that stuff.
Meanwhile, we've dropped a record number of
bombs on Afghanistan.
So did you know about this?
Did you know that your tax dollars, while
Trump slams other presidents for the military
decisions that they made or slammed Hillary
for the military decisions, she would have
made your tax dollars have gone to a record
number of bomb drops under the Trump administration
in Afghanistan.
We're not winning hearts and minds there.
We're not even talking about winning hearts
and minds.
Nevermind actually winning hearts and minds.
Taxpayers are still paying for the bombs.
The money is flowing freely to the defense
contractors and we have no idea where, why
we are still there.
We are in year, I don't know, is it 18 or
19 at this point?
We must be getting really close to dropping
enough bombs for them to work the way we want,
right?
Or otherwise.
Why do we continue to do it?
It's a really good thing that that warmonger
Hillary Clinton didn't get into office and
quite frankly, I don't even, I'm sort of saying
that as a satire because this might be identical
under Hillary.
It just continues on one, uh, under one president
under another, on and on and on.
So this is a story as much as it is about
Donald Trump's failed promises when it comes
to the middle East, foreign intervention bombings,
war, military conflict.
This is also a story about the military industrial
complex, about as much as it is about our
foreign policy and that needs to be mentioned.
What have these bombs achieved for us?
If we had dropped 4,000 bombs last year in
Afghanistan instead of 8,000, would things
be different?
Would we be less safe?
We know that there are defense contractors
that would have less money, but we would because
of uh, not spending that money, uh, and spreading
that military, uh, sort of approach or the
use of the military that Donald Trump claimed
he would actually reel back in.
Uh, it's still is being alleged that it made
sense to abandon the Kurds in Northern Syria,
right?
Because Hey, Trump promised he would get us
out of places and he would scale back and
all this stuff.
We are told that abandoning the Kurds made
sense for those reasons, but yet we are dropping
a record number of bombs in Afghanistan and
it just goes on and on with no end and no
point and no conclusion insight.
So step one is knowing about this, and I know
a lot of people in our audience didn't know
about this.
I think we mentioned it briefly in December.
Uh, when there were preliminary numbers about
bombs dropped in Afghanistan, we now have
the final numbers and it is absolutely sickening
what is going on.
I would be shocked if any significant portion
of our audience was even aware of this and
that's part of how it continues.
Important to know that